por aquí tengo a esta gráfica y por acá
por este lado tengo cuatro posibles
definiciones de esta gráfica y ahora lo
que quiero que hagas es que pase a ese
libro
justo ahora y pienses en cuál de estas
cuatro definiciones de funciones me
dibujan a esta gráfica que tenemos
representada justo aquí
y bueno suponiendo que ya pausas del
vídeo vamos a resolverlo lo primero que
quiero que notes es que aquí tenemos
cuatro funciones y todas ellas tienen
involucrado a logaritmo en base 2 de x a
logaritmo en base 2 de x por lo tanto
sería muy bueno recordar cómo se ve
nuestra función si bien es igual al
logaritmo al logaritmo en base 2 de x ok
y ya con esto después con calma podemos
ver qué es lo que pasa cuando sumamos 1
o cuando restamos 1 o cuando desplazamos
un poco esta función ahora pensemos
primero en algunos valores interesantes
para esta función y es igual a logaritmo
en base 2 t x así que déjame poner aquí
a x por aquí voy a poner ayer ok y vamos
a pensar en algunos de estos valores
interesantes
déjame hacer algo así ok y vamos a
pensar qué es lo que pasa cuando x vale
2 cuando x vale 2 bueno lo que estoy
diciendo es que tengo que es igual al
logaritmo en base dos de dos
o bueno también lo podemos ver de la
siguiente forma a qué potencia tengo que
elevar 2 es decir la base para que me dé
2 y bueno eso es muy sencillo esa es la
primera potencia por lo tanto lo voy a
poner aquí el logaritmo base dos de dos
es uno y ahora si nosotros pensamos en
no esperar mejor déjeme ante capital
esto de aquí y vamos a empezar con un
valor un poco más grande para que
entonces nos vayamos en orden
descendente cuando x vale x
ok el lugar 2 de 8 es lo mismo que decir
a qué potencia tendrán que elevar el 2
para obtener 8 y bueno la respuesta es 3
porque 2 al cubo es 8 y yo pongo aquí 4
bueno pues 2 elevado a la segunda
potencia media 4 por lo tanto el lugar y
no en base 2 de 4 es 2 ok y si yo pongo
dos vueltas eso ya lo sabemos el lugar
en base a dos dedos es a que potencie
tengo que eleva el 2 para obtener el 2 y
eso es a la primera potencia muy bien y
si yo pongo 1 ok y estoy diciendo a que
potencia tengo que elevar el 2 para que
me dé 1 y bueno nosotros sabemos la
respuesta la respuesta es sí
muy bien y si ahora pongo por ejemplo un
medio si pongo por ejemplo un medio a
qué potencia tenemos que elevar el 2
para obtener un medio y nosotros sabemos
que la respuesta es menos 1 una potencia
negativa ok y si yo pongo por ejemplo un
cuarto en cuarto el logaritmo en base 2
de un cuarto es exactamente lo mismo que
pensar a qué potencia tengo que llevar 2
para que me dé un cuarto lo cual es
menos 2 ok yo pongo por ejemplo ham para
finalizar un octavo un octavo bueno pues
podemos pensar a qué potencia tengo que
llevar el 2 para que me dé un octavo o
dicho otra manera el logaritmo en base 2
de un octavo que es menos tres menos
tres y bueno pues vamos a graficar estos
puntos cuando x vale 8 que vale 3
ok estamos justo aquí cuando x vale 4
bien vale 2 ok
justo aquí cuando x vale 2 llévale 1
mouse por aquí cuando x vale 1 vale cero
estamos justo por aquí y ya puedes ir
observando qué forma va a tomar esta
gráfica cuando x vale un medio que vale
menos 1 estamos como por aquí ok
cuando x vale un cuarto que vale menos
dos estamos como por aquí y ahora nos
pegamos un poco más cuando equivale un
octavo que vale menos tres estamos justo
por aquí y ahora si quiero conectar a
todos estos puntos me va a quedar una
gráfica más o menos si con él tenemos
todos estos puntos me voy acercando por
aquí ok y después por aquí va a pasar ni
gráfica
y después va a ir tomando a su por su
forma más o menos
tomando una forma más o menos así esto
me agrada aunque y después algo así
esto me agrada y bueno date cuenta que
el comportamiento de los extremos es
completamente como lo esperábamos cuando
x hace cada vez más y más grande
entonces el lugar y no en base 2 de x
sigue creciendo y cuando x se acerque y
se acerque se acerca a cero entonces
quien toma valores cada vez más
negativos dicho de otra manera cuando
nosotros nos acercamos y nos acercamos y
nos acercamos a cero entonces la
potencia y la que tenemos que elevar 2
es cada vez más negativa y eso es muy
importante cuando x se acerca a 0
entonces la función y es igual al hogar
en base 2 de x toma valores cada vez más
y más y más negativos y de hecho nunca
podemos obtener el valor de 0 si
nosotros ponemos aquí el valor de 0 y
decimos a qué potencia tenemos que
elevar el 2 para obtener 0 bueno pues
eso no se puede
puedes acercarte mucho mucho mucho a
cero elevando al 2 a números muy pero
muy pero muy negativos pero nunca puedes
obtener
y de hecho esta función no está definida
para valores negar o mejor dicho para
valores que no sean positivos nada que
no sea menor o igual que 0 el dominio de
esta función son todas las x positivas
pero bueno lo que nosotros queremos
encontrar es cuál de estas funciones
tiene como gráfica esta función de azul
y si te das cuenta lo primero que me
salta a la vista de esta gráfica es que
está girada con respecto al eje de las
equis a comparación de esta gráfica que
tenemos de color magenta lo cual es una
clara señal de que tenemos el logaritmo
en base 2 de x pero negativo 10 más
vamos a graficar la cómo se vería la
función y es igual a menos el logaritmo
el logaritmo en base 2 de x bueno pues
lo que va a pasar es que todos estos
puntos se van a dar la vuelta con
respecto al eje x este punto se va a
pasar justo aquí este punto se va a
pasar justo aquí
este punto se va a pasar justo por aquí
ok
bueno este punto se mantiene igual date
cuenta que se mantiene igual ya que este
valor de un medio se va a pasar justo
para acá
georges y si unimos todos estos puntos
que voy a obtener déjame ver si los
puedo decir de una manera muy rápida
este se va a ir pegando más o menos así
va a quedar algo más o menos así se ve
pegando y pegando y pegando el eje de
asier y después aquí estos dos se van a
unir más o menos así algo más o menos
así ok esto también se va a pegar más o
menos así o que ya va tomando mejor
forma algo más uno así y por último hay
que unir éste
así más o menos así más o menos así se
vería la gráfica de esta función de y es
igual a menos el logaritmo en base 2 de
x ahora seguramente te vas a preguntar
cuáles son las diferencias que hay entre
esta gráfica de verde y esta gráfica de
azul y bueno si tú no ves de una manera
detenida te vas a dar cuenta que esta
gráfica de azul es la misma que esta
gráfica de verde solamente que todos sus
puntos se han desplazado dos unidades
hacia la izquierda se han desplazado dos
unidades hacia la izquierda todos sus
puntos
date cuenta que este punto se va a pasar
para acá este punto se va a pasar para
acá y todo se ha recorrido dos unidades
hacia la izquierda y como podemos hacer
que una gráfica se desplace todas dos
unidades hacia la izquierda
bueno pues reemplazar la x con x + 2
reemplazarla x con x +
ok y una forma de ver esto es que en la
función original y es igual a menos el
lugar y no en base 2 de x podemos ver la
cinta cuando x es igual a 0 ahora vamos
a verla sin tota cuando esta expresión
esta expresión está igual a 0 x + 2 es
igual a 0 y bueno x + 2 es igual a cero
cuando x es igual a menos 2 por eso
puedes verlas into está justo aquí aquí
puedes ver la acin total cuando x vale
menos 2 porque lo que estamos haciendo
es tomar x + 2 igual a cero así que te
voy a encargar que tú pruebes con
algunos valores si tú quieres que
esencialmente es tomarse todos estos
valores y restarles dos para que después
de que tú le sumas dos regreses de nuevo
estos valores y verifica que en verdad
es esta la función en fin entonces
podemos decir que cuando desplazamos una
función dos unidades hacia la izquierda
estamos reemplazando a x
x2 así que esta es la función que está
clasificada de color azul está de clint
ok y una vez más intenta con algunos
valores si tú no me querés